Matt Ryan who joins us on the program
the Falcons quarterback do you keep up
with all this other stuff going on in
the NFL it's hard to miss it you know I
had a think popped up on my phone with
the ESPN breaking news so I saw that
this morning you know I keep up with it
a little bit I'm a sports fan you know
so I see it but I don't I don't really
chase it but it's hard to miss it at
this point but you know one day you're
gonna be in a situation like Eli Zinn
right you just assume that I you know
you hope not you hope you're on the end
where it's like Tom Brady and you're
playing it right you know if you got six
Super Bowls or whatever you know that's
still that's still my goal but
inevitably I've been around it long
enough to know that most guys don't go
out on their own terms
and that's kind of the harsh nature of
our business but also when the team
drafts a quarterback because you know
Brady even though he's still playing
they drafted quarterbacks and you know
Jared Stidham now people looking at him
as the heir apparent and before that it
was Jimmy Garoppolo you know we've seen
these situations here how much of a role
do you play in developing a younger
quarterback well you know I think it's
first and foremost your job is is to be
productive as a player and and that's
where your main focus is that I've kind
of been on the opposite side of it I've
had backup quarterback two of their
veterans for most of my career currently
you know Matt's job is my backup and
he's older than me so it's it's it's one
of a kind of Mentor against ku but I
think you know when you in that position
you do the best you can to be the best
player you can but then you also help
creme and help develop the guy below you
I know your kids are young I think
you're twins or what under - yeah so 18
months do they know what you do do they
have any other what's it like when dad
comes home zero idea we just it's
probably moving like everybody else
don't get along you get the same you're
you know on the floor playing with the
with the boys and you
pushing them around at Amazon boxes
right now do they understand football
and they they pick up the ball and they
want to play basketball football soccer
they love they love anything anything
with a ball so we've got the Falcons
when the boys were born got them to game
balls with their hands and buildable
stuff and they're in their room right
now so when they wake up you know
they're always asking for their ball and
stuff like that we prosecutor the coach
and we got a little Fisher prices for
that forum so there's plenty of
opportunities play sports in our house
what if they when they get to the point
for Christmas they say eh
dad can I get a Patrick mahomes Jersey
who do you consider the best quarterback
in the NFL extremely well off to a great
start this year again and then you talk
about Tom Brady and you know two
different interviews and he's playing at
a high level so I think there's a lot of
guys in the league right now operating
really well into position we often talk
about system quarterbacks and I think
there's it feels like you know is Tom
Brady in a system where is maybe Payton
man and created his own system or Brett
Favre created his own system do you do
you look at are you in a system with the
Falcons I think we are and you know I I
kind of let's think that's there's no
negative to that if your production is
is good you know who cares if you're
creating the system where the system is
created you if the production is there
to me at the end of the day that's
that's ultimately the most important day
but I think all of us benefit off of of
great coaching and people putting us in
positions to be successful when you're
looking at the game film against the
Eagles with three touchdowns three
interceptions and you're there with
everybody
what happens when they get to the
touchdowns and then how do you feel when
they get to the interceptions oh you
always feel like that when they get to
the to the interceptions you never you
know you know those mistakes and you
never want to put your team in a tough
spot but it's part of it and I think
more so than anything you know taking
ownership of mistakes and teammates
understanding that you know being around
that I think that sets a good you know a
good culture for our game and then the
touchdowns are the ones you like you
know those are those are the ones when
we watch it you're trying to find ways
to get more of them and we had some good
ones the other night what happens though
when you know your receiver ran the
wrong route but you don't want to call
him out on the field like how do you
handle that when somebody did something
that you're the one that's going to get
blamed to me you know you make sure we
all know that the correction needs to be
made but Sunday's are about championing
your teammates you know I think it's
hard enough in this league you're
playing against great players there's
the environment them there's all those
things there's no need to you know bring
each other down and games is about
uplifting each other and make it you all
as confident as we can be I think the
corrections and the time for for you
know making sure we're accountable to
each other is during the week of
practice and in our meeting rooms you
know my style is being tough Olympics or
weaker than what we get for Sunday it's
about playing together and trying to
accomplish the goal of the game together
what do you do better now that at 34
that you didn't do in 24 my preparation
is so much better you know of getting
ready during the week being prepared to
playoffs I think I'm more resilient at
this point in my career you know you
take a look at the game the other night
and you know we have a couple of
interceptions and kind of the momentum
turned in a second half and I think at
this point in my career of better at
being able to put that behind you
focusing on the best drives and make it
the next play and I think that comes
from experience the call to Julio that
won the game against the Eagles
is that a call or an autumn oh I always
say you know in in our play call
we had an empty formation running
basically out to be you know zone
organics and then we had an alert that
if they went to cover zero we were going
to the play that we ran and so it's a
building inaudible I guess the best way
to describe it
oh you're trying to dumb it down so I
can understand it Matt I was the
starting quarterback as a freshman on
the Freshman team in high school just
letting you know so I think how did you
how did your audible work how did you
guys honorable in that system for your
system gonna did you create the system I
was the system man basically I was
saying Des Moines I didn't say Omaha I
was saying Des Moines Des Moines just to
let you know to come do you have a
favorite audible like word so you know
it's probably gonna have to get changed
from last night we all could have
enjoyed of these fellows after that game
is that one could you do one for us
against the Colts we have one of our
guys here football guy named McLovin
could you use McLovin as an audible
maybe against the Colts here yeah I will
add something to squeak after I finished
with this interview I'm gonna call Turk
cutter and make sure we have something
that they're called that mclovin checks
and I'm sure Dirk is gonna go oh yeah
yeah yeah hell yeah I I hope to hear you
like that he's pretty open about that oh
my god you'll go down and Dan Patrick
show history if you do yes McLovin and
what this might be asking for too much
brick it can I design the play as well
no no no no no we just want we just want
the audible maybe Calvin really go along
I'm just saying wow that's great
hey how about throw the banner Julio
that's probably either of those two
suggestions are probably good
suggestions there you have it look now
we're
really gonna be watching that game
against the cult and you know in that
building you know we should be able to
hear it echo you know when you yell it
out it should be perfect it should be
perfect you know with the way the
microphones are set up I like it Payton
had that place trained for four audibles
and all that kind of stuff so we should
be ready to go I love it thank you Matt
always good to catch up with you and
hope the family's well I appreciate it
thank you
that's Matt run four more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
Direct TV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]